professor Martin we are delighted that
you are here with us at Yale we're
delighted also that you have taken the
time to participate in this in this
little conversation that you and I will
be having I think it's probably fair to
say that you are well known for very
early contestation of the so-called
secularization thesis namely that as
modernization progresses so there will
be decline in religion decline in the
numbers of people adhering to religion
decline of social influence of religion
religion seems to be thriving today is
it well I think it's thriving a lot more
than my particular colleagues that held
the secularization thesis which I
criticized him about 43 years ago and it
the problem is that the second is a ssin
thesis works in one or two areas of the
world notably the one I live in and it
doesn't really work elsewhere and my
view at the time when I criticized it
was that was what's now called Europe
European exceptionalism I I phrased it
in terms of is the whole world going to
be like France or Sweden or both
together and I concluded it just wasn't
and so from that annoyed my colleagues
who believed in something called
American exceptionalism and this was
really a game of odd man out which of us
is on the road you know he is on the
high road to the future and I concluded
that it was possible that so Western
Europe was not at least the single high
road the future might be one of the ways
into modernity but there was American
Way an American Way which was very
different and that was connected with
historical circumstances the particular
historical circumstances of Europe the
ticular historical circumstances of
america and that the rest of the world
as Peter Berger has put it was quite
furiously were just religious although
one has to think about China as well
because that's a very complicated
question right but on the whole it seems
like the developments have proven you to
be to be right why do you think the
world is continuing to be religious what
functions does religion play in lives of
people so that they continue to embrace
it or maybe even as I'm asking this
question I ask myself is this the right
way to pose the question or again is
what Peter Berger whom you have
mentioned should we not use his phrase
and say well what really needs to be
explaining needs explaining his
secularism and not religious faith which
was with us throughout the history of
humanity well it is another version of
the who's the old man out exactly is the
is the rationalism the the natural
position or is the religion somehow the
natural position I'm and I'm not sure
about any any any approach that assumes
that something is built-in so naturally
that's going to reproduce itself and
reproduce itself I'm rather strong on
the historical side that it depends on
the circumstances what interest me at
the moment is that the rather aggressive
biological approach that some certainly
very popular in Britain and has has it
representatives here can be used to
suggest that religion is built-in I
don't like the phrase hardwired because
I think I think it's built in socially
rather than I mean there may be a
biological element of you can't be
certain exactly what that is but that
the quest for meaning and the quest for
quest for identity these two things too
the meaning and identity are pretty
fundamental and meaning purpose and
identity if you add those three together
there are pretty powerful trio and
reason doesn't really
and certainly empirical science is not
actually designed to answer mm-hmm that
kind of question so that's the area of
that religion occupies though this isn't
to say that the two don't that that they
have a strictly demarcated frontier
that's that doesn't seem to me the case
but it I do feel that there is a
fundamental sense of Who am I where am I
going
what is the meaning of my life how is it
rooted right right right right
and maybe the processes of modernization
kind of uproot people disorient placed
him in the kind of swirling storm off a
rapid change and religion or faith may
give orientation in as well as meaning
in life yes I think that some of the and
the speed of change can actually mean
that the questions of I of Who am I
where am I going become all that much
much more urgent yeah that's very
interesting
now many faiths see understand
themselves as ways of life I think of
Islam for instance I think of
Christianity also certainly Judaism
Christianity certainly in earlier
incarnations can faith be lived as kind
of integral way of life under the
conditions of modernity or must one
think of faith and maybe must is too
strong but is faith do people tend to
live their faith as an aspect of life
which then one way or the other
irradiate to other ways of life other
aspects of life but really is not
central to them well this raises
question of
what is modernity and who's in the
modern world
this was another point in which I was
inclined to challenge my colleagues who
certainly believed that London was
modern but had their doubts about
Atlanta and certainly felt that Cairo
was living in a different different
period altogether so we're in fact but
all all headed in the direction of
London right in terms of development
well it could be London but it might be
berming or it might be birdie and I have
the feeling that Berlin is ultimately
that the secular place so what was it
what was thought of as a sequence became
a kind of spatial division you know
we're moving forward for different
stages yeah and the real modernity
is what goes on in Berlin and somehow
one or two of one or two places like
Atlanta and Little Rock are somehow got
stuck in an earlier phase so it's that's
a question of that's a question about
who's modern yeah I think the other the
other question is well let me say this
been phased faced by small items that in
terms of you know alternative modernity
the theory was that people were moving
towards the same modernity and certainly
I felt and it's now been formulated very
strongly by smaller Isis that that there
are various ways of being modern two or
three of the main ones I think are very
contrasted if one takes the Islamic way
it tends to try and reassert as certain
unities and those unities would be those
of territory power and faith and way of
life so that there's a kind of integral
relation between these
three and that is certainly one way of
being modern but it means that you have
to devise certain techniques for making
sure that modernity doesn't start to
erode the this disunity particularly by
allowing pluralism to take off due to a
- to accept the idea of religious choice
rather than religious birthright mm-hmm
so the contrast between what you might
call the birthright religions related to
power and territory and a way of life
which is a way of the people and the
other side which is represented in the
United States where your world is is
more disparate that you operate in in
one sphere in in a technologically
dominated rationalistic sphere a
bureaucratic sphere and you think of
your religion as an aspect of life and
an aspect of your existence then at
least just a theory I'm not absolutely
certain that this is a case even in the
United States because lots of people I I
meet in the u.s. want to link up these
different spheres and feel that
fundamentally if you are a person of
faith and it should extend into all
aspects of your life but in terms of the
fundamental first logical theory it is
that you've got functional
differentiation and the big one for the
you for the u.s. is really the
separation of church and state and the
separation of territory and of religion
those two separations I think are quite
an choice yes those three things are the
the American and the American Way of
being modern and the reverse I think is
the let's take Islam as the
the other cave yeah and and if I hear
you rightly that they also have their
own possibly attendant ways of life so
that depending on the the situating
oneself how one situates oneself in
modernity and how one understands
modernity of being modern one can live
faith as a way of life it'll be
different but nonetheless it will be
still a way of life yes right
you mentioned the separation of of
differentiation social differentiation
and especially in the United States were
at least in theory very clear separation
between church and in state and that
then begs the question of the influence
of religion or faiths in public realm
that influence is palpable in this
country also so as can you speak more
about the various may be modes of
influence or public role of religion or
what what what comes to your mind as you
think about possibilities of faiths
influence in the present day globalized
context well I have a kind of spectrum
of possibility and if one took the
Islamic one and went in ended the and
the American one at the other and I were
to move quickly along that spectrum I
would take the Russian Orthodox the or
the Orthodox Eastern European one as one
where religion for various reasons has
been very closely related to it to
identity and especially to ethnic
identity and that's something that you
would be very good conscious off from
your background and so that the church
is actually especially the Orthodox
Church is not really judged in terms of
its separate existence as an
organizational entity as it is evening
Catholicism it actually is the what
people do it's how people live their
lives and how they identify with their
land and with their nation and how they
pay reverence to their
land if I can put this yeah there's a
kind of sense of the power of being in a
particular place and of manifestations
of evil and of good that somehow operate
out there not necessarily as the evil of
the will manifestations of evil
manifestations of of good and also of
continuity the continuity of the
generations and that's part of not
religion not being a matter of choice
but being a matter of being where you
are and that kind of person so that's
the next the next one away from Islam
and the next one after that is really
Catholicism where you've got a space
some kind of space between church and
state they're not all Catholicism is
like this yeah focus ala system isn't
but most of the countries of Europe have
an 80% participant will belong it to a
particular in one particular faith and
in those circumstances it depends a lot
on what they what the history is the one
took the French example it would be one
where the myth of the nation was count
opposed to the the the Catholic faith
the nation emerged in Contra distinction
to Catholicism enlightened plus nation
versus Catholicism equals
anti-clericalism equals in the end the
separation of church and state and the
very strong assumption that religion is
a private matter so that's the next one
along the along the spectrum
I'll just step in two more if I one is
the British one I think which is half
when the Britain is really halfway
across the Atlantic and lots of fur lots
of ways which is that the the church
operates for the kind of umbrella for
all kinds of expressions of faith as
well as a master of ceremonies for times
of national rejoicing and
and morning and so on so it is a sacred
space at the center of the nation even
if people don't bother to go to that
speak for the space very regularly so
and there you don't have you certainly
don't have as you've have on the
continent in Christian as you had in
Christian democracy a Christian
political party what you do have is a
diffuse presence of Christianity and
someone gets to the United States and
which I take is really the center of the
question and here you have the strictest
separation of church and state and the
most voluble participation of
faith-based organizations in thee in the
public sphere to a degree that just
would not happen I mean people would
never in Britain address their
complications telling them implicitly
telling them how to vote or so that the
the American one is paradoxical I think
in the degree of influence of of
religion actually has as compared with
the degree of separation and so the
formal separation can go hand-in-hand
with really material strong material
forms of forms of influence actually you
have a mentioned number of different
denominations or church groupings which
have their own different styles of being
Christian and living in the modern world
one that you have studied very carefully
and that most people haven't is
Pentecostalism there's an immense growth
of Pentecostalism world wide
how is Pentecostalism linked to and
growth of Pentecostalism links to
globalization
trends and processes well I see
Pentecostalism as the the final
expression of the American idea and I
don't mean that it it is actually an
American this is certainly an American
base religion what I'm saying is that
the that the idea of personal experience
linked to individual choice those two
things together they're rather obvious
but it's but nevertheless in in the case
of Pentecostalism it expresses itself in
a fundamentally lay religion that the
the hierarchical mediation of God is
really set aside and it to the extent
that it exists it really comes through a
charismatic lay pastor yeah I know the
pastor is not strictly lay but I mean it
is yeah it these are charisma these are
charismatic gifts that are available to
everybody and that seems to me to be a
very it well I happen to think it's a
very Christian principle I think the
priesthood of all believers is actually
what America picked up it took that part
of the Christian repertoire and and it
fitted quite well with democracy whereas
in in Europe hierarchy and and church
statements and and church interventions
in how people ought to behave though
that was not particularly Democrat in I
also think that it's somehow significant
that one of the main basis of
Pentecostalism was lost anthony's
because flanger los angeles is about the
most decentralized place on earth I mean
it doesn't have it doesn't have a
central core from which everything else
emanates and it's always seemed to me
that Pentecostalism is is like that
that's that's very interesting
connection with the space of Los Angeles
and the character of Pentecostalism you
mentioned charismatic leaders and
once seized I think in terms of
influence in today's world in in other
denominations as well as in religions
the importance of charismatic leader
with kind of informal networks bin Laden
may be a good example yeah one and
technicon may be another example Rick
Warren may be also another example and
we can link multiple multiply those
examples are is this kind of charismatic
leader is this how do you explain the
significance and prominence but I think
of prominent leaders I think of course
there's some like in the John uh like
john paul ii or sixteen but there's this
also very significant other phenomenon I
think the Pentecostalism is is
paradoxical in lots of ways and one is
that and if you have anything as free as
this where everybody can you know that
the gifts of the Spirit can light on
anybody at anytime you there are also
people that are on whom the gifts
forward even with some plenitude and and
they exercise some I see them as
religious entrepreneurs with enormous
spiritual energy energies of every kind
actually yeah who are running their own
show and and that's what really apart
from the essence of Pentecostalism which
is prayer and praise but but the essence
is this kind of energy of independent
religious on foreigners running their
own shows and doing so on a
decentralized and pluralistic
competitive basis and globalization
provides the ways technological means to
reach every corner of the world right
instantly oh absolutely
and but the authority of the posture and
the freedom of the congregation I
believe go together so that you you
could not have that degree of freedom
without some pretty strong assertions of
authority right I'm being aware of when
that when people are speaking in
tongues there's a point at which that
the pastor indicates that this is the
moment to wish it stops and everybody
implicitly understands that this moment
is over and another moment is beginning
right right right
it's it's interesting that in
Pentecostal churches in Pentecostal
traditions in addition to these kind of
D central well the the can splash in
energy from below which of course needs
the central authority occurs matically
constituted but nonetheless authority so
in addition to that you have strong
presence of of women and women in
leadership roles also so what what do
you see is there as a relationship
between two Pentecostalism and and
gender if you can put it in those terms
of women in as a religious actors yes
well of course all all religions all
Christian religions anyway that that's
probably a an important proviso mm-hmm
all verses Christians have a very strong
predominance of women it will be as true
in the Orthodox Church yeah it is an a
Pentecostal church but I think there are
some specific things in relation to
Pentecostalism I've sometimes called it
a trade union of global trade union of
women so alongside the the past trip
which i think is a very important
element I call them the Buried
intelligentsia
and people of enormous energy and I
suspect great intelligence alongside
that our is our women who want stability
who want above all they want the man
brought back in and whereas Western
feminism was to let the woman out as a
family the rest of the world is is in a
situation where one-third the man
brought back in and to act responsibly
within the family so a stable monogamous
family offers
a great deal to women and many of the
biographies that I have collected our
[ __ ] of women have been abused in
different ways by wayward men and men
who have destroyed the economic base of
their family by a combination of drink
drugs smoking and and women really but
by by simply moving from one woman to
another and leaving letters of children
in different in different places now
that is a very widespread phenomenon in
Ashley put it quite sexist societies
that was where it's a it's a patriarchal
ism which is basically based on the
rights of man and not the rights of a
woman and and what Pentecostalism does
even though it it it says yes the woman
should say the man is the head of the
woman all the same this has to be a
relationship of mutual respect and of a
common discipline asserted in in the
family and once you get men vector
shifts from they they shift from
addictions to to things that destroy the
family and these are turned into
aversions once you get them then the
women find that they they have a
reliable man who is the the the core of
the family structure and a lot of
Pentecostal sermons are directed some of
them quite vigorous against male rampage
that's very interesting now know we at
this moment in you know united states
there is a very prominent Pentecostal is
women yeah she's running as a vice
presidential running mate of Senator
McCain for the for for the office well
what do you take to be
significance of this is eveni well one
one thing that occurs to me is that some
the the most likely woman up to this
point was Hillary Clinton and she comes
from the the faith which was the
progenitor of Pentecostal is very
interesting but it could just now be a
Pentecost list as if there's a kind of
sequence here a natural sequence from
from from one to the other that's the
first thing the other is event well
there's been a kind of evolution of
Pentecostalism I think from a religion
of them they marginalized in
particularly in the south - after the
convulsions of the sixties I would say
that some forms of evangelicalism an
including Pentecostalism tend to
intended to move to the republic move
more to the republican side because they
along with all these and all the virtues
of Pentecostalism there's a very strong
fear of moral deterioration and that
expresses itself in various ways one of
which is gender and I would say that the
Pentecostals have a strong sense of
what's manly and what's womanly and that
this this element is something that's
picked up by Sarah Palin my experience
with Pentecostal women is they're pretty
strong characters so even when they are
living within what would be called an
American terms a conservative context
they are actually extremely they're
powerful they're powerful women and so
you've got this the same a paradox
really of a really powerful one within a
a conservative context and I suspect
that from the point of view of McCain
who may not have been the favorite
person of evangelicals that Sarah Palin
has a strong womanly woman appealed to a
sector of of the American electorate and
one which is my face would be sniffing
the overlooked by quite a large part of
the well the liberal elite does exist so
I'm going to use that term yes when the
liberal elite doesn't really regard
these people in there's a book by Joe
bagent I don't know if he was called
deer hunting for Jesus which I know it's
a form of a form of journalism we
haven't quite achieved him in Britain
but but it relates it to Winchester in
Virginia and and he talks about them as
my people he's liberal but he goes back
to his people and he and and he has some
sympathy with their sense of really not
being regarded fully and and I think
that she picks up some of them well from
powerful womanly women maybe at the end
of our conversation we lift a helicopter
up a bit bit higher and if I may invoke
the name of Samuel haunting haunting
tongue yeah and his famous suggestion I
suppose that the fault lines in the
world run along major civilizations
which are then divine defined also by
major religions and the thesis of clash
of civilizations as you observe the
world of religion world of faiths and
the processes of globalization how do
you respond to Samuel Huntington's
thesis well as I've looked around the
world and look to what you might call
the pressure points I mean it has struck
me even even before
Huntington's formulation that those
pressure points have lie pretty close to
the fault lines of world confessions
again thinking in terms of your your own
backgrounds that they that the
transition between the eastern and
western Christendom runs through the the
Balkans and and next to that was the
Ottoman Empire if you will add the
Ottoman Empire with the division between
east and west and those three elements
together it's not saying that this is so
much always a question of of religion
but there there is a complex of factors
to do with nation and to do with
political authority and to do with yes
with who who you are actually what kind
of identity you adopt and heyou identify
with once all those things come together
in the inner and it in one of these
areas of transition then there is likely
to be serious trouble the same is true
of the caucuses that you've had the
again it's very much political and
economic I mean Russia pushed into the
caucuses which was and it picked up
Christian nations like Georgia and
Armenia one of them and that's part of
the expansion of empire so that's
political but also there's the pipeline
that's economic yeah then you add into
that the religious one that the
Georgians needed originally to appeal to
Russia to defend them for against the
power of another Empire so it's all to
do with empires and economics and we
didn't together
and do you do you in this one way to
read these thesis wouldn't it would be
to say that well precisely as identity
shaping civilization and therefore
identity shaping factor our religion is
also conflict
generating or conflict legitimizing
among other factors as you mentioned
political and economic and so on and so
forth
what happens or are they resources in
religions or in religions that that see
themselves as transnational that see
themselves as world religions not just
to stabilize local identities but to to
cross and make bridges between various
civilizations and identities yes well
that's the big one isn't it I mean it it
is ending on the big one well let me say
one thing that I think is fundamental
and and that is that that human
solidarity is based either biologically
also socially or so so biologically I'm
inclined to stress the social but the
the the the solidarity I'm simply
calling on the biologist for further
support if that's necessary to say that
the the sense of us and them is that is
central to to to having a sense of us
that that these two things are very
closely related there and they are part
of the fundamentals of social
organization so I suspect his status
that status anxiety is something
absolutely fundamental so you have to
add status and and asking them those two
things are built built-in and religion
the religions of the last 3,000 years
have tried to break out of that that's
and they've done so in terms of did a
declaration of the unity of the human
race now the problem there is that one
person's unity is another person's one
person's unity is an us as against
somebody else's unity which is of them
so every assertion of unity
actually creates a border this is my
unity